tales studio à montréal en direct à 11 à
11 nous saluons la planète qui nous
accueillent dans leur vie quotidienne
bonjour à tous
alors cette entame canada en direct de
montréal faut-il le répéter
et c'est sur toutes les plateformes
facebook youtube et radio canada
international donc si soleil réseau le
site de radio canada international
on voit ça en ce moment moi je n'ai
jamais vu parce qu'on est toujours en
direct nous on peut pas se détacher
j'y pense et le jour j'ai dit j'aimerais
bien voir comment ce à quoi ça ressemble
alors faudra peut-être quelques films
pour nous comme ça sur son ordinateur ce
qui se passe en ce moment et nous
l'envoyer en fichiers mp3 de préférence
mais surtout mp4 parce qu'elle abîme
l'image avec selon moi c'est sérieux si
vous pouvez le faire fait le extrait dix
secondes pas plus on n'en demande pas
beaucoup pour notre cadeau de noël ici
autour de la table il y aller au gym et
notre expert en questions techniques
bonjour bonjour il ya maryse jobin ma
collègue de plusieurs années avec nous
avec lee c est ainsi qu avec la nôtre
vis aussi personnel toujours collègue
marié et maintenant y'a alléchante à le
champ dame qui est avec nous plongera
les seins elle a des couleurs brillantes
pouvait penser à une représentation une
ambassadrice d'un pays quelconque une
ambassadrice depuis quelques angoisses
pas de la chine parce que le rouge est
très prédominance non belles couleurs
africaines inquiet vous êtes toujours
habité habité par gaby c'est vrai que
l'afrique est très très colorier mais
bon c'est jovial moi c'est ce que je
retiens de ma vie en afrique les
couleurs le soleil et puis les couleurs
écoutez c'est le retour en classe donc
votre fiston y rentrer mais oui sur
paris lundi pas de recul on peut encore
parce que si les de recul on peut pas
avancer pour nom il avance plutôt bien
m'arrive jamais votre grand garçon c'est
fini l'école oui et c'est fini pour moi
de payer ces droits scolaires ou c'est à
l'université parce qu'il porte un
appartement grand garçon et voilà quel
âge
vet faut-il le dire on s'en souvient
encore
tous les mois les miels et 13 sont
partis à l'école ce bon débarras ma 10
mai de 0,8
alors écoutez on est prêt pour le sujet
du jour vous connaissez la stratégie que
nous employer champ que chaque semaine
c'est très web notre affaire comment ça
fonctionne c'est le questionnaire des
questionnaires visuel à en cinq images
les voici tout le monde à la maison au
bureau ou sur le chantier vous regarder
ensemble et on joue ici en studio on
tente de deviner ce qu'on ne sait pas
quel est le sujet aujourd'hui des
missions vous en avez parlé on soit tous
les deux cette année onze fois tout
l'héroïne gaz les réfugiés camps de
réfugiés pensez vous continuer à
regarder attentivement
quel est le sujet aujourd'hui aide
humanitaire
pensez vous continuer à regarder vous
avez utilisé ces images les déplacés
moquer jégo ingalls
oui j'en ai parlé à m pris plusieurs
fois je pense vous avez le record au
niveau des gens en effet seulement 3
vous en avais je pense ça non mais parce
que c'est un sujet qui vient me chercher
c'est vraiment humain c'est des
personnes qui vivent vraiment dans une
situation une situation vraiment
déplorable
ils sont en proie à la merci des
intempéries les femmes qui sont violées
les enfants qui vont pas à l'école qui
enfin donc ça ne laisse personne
indifférent c c'est un triste
anniversaire en ce moment c'est la
première année qu'on souligne en ce
moment depuis quelques jours de ceux de
cet exode des wings qui habitèrent ou en
birmanie
autrefois vont un peu se sont rendus
beaucoup d'entre eux étaient des
personnes apatrides
donc ils n'ont pas de nation précise
qu'ils se retrouvent dans aérer un peu
partout pour le moment il se il se
retrouve du côté du bangladesh où ils
sont vraiment y vivent dans la nature
franchement c'est une situation
pratiquement invivable et surtout des
religions n'est seulement que vous en
savez des choses on va avoir une
spécialiste avec nous qui en sait encore
plus puisqu'elle est allé sur le terrain
nous les journalistes aujourd'hui on se
prend pas très loin mais les les ong
vont partout notamment les ong
canadienne mais avant de réfléchir avant
de le dévoiler le visage de cette digne
représentante canadienne
au bangladesh qui est de retour de
mission je vais vous proposer une courte
vidéo préparée par son organisation
pour vous mettre dans le bain un
témoignage d'une personne qui se trouve
présentement au bangladesh car il ya les
bureaux installés des carmes vial a des
atouts sur l'île des chasseurs de
libreville it was too close and not move
de rosenau et à l'échelle politique
d'islande et spleen sur le d algérie et
10 km
alors s'est préparée par l'organisme
canadien qui s'appelle développement et
paix qui est seulement un organisme de
solidarité internationale de l'église
catholique au canada et qui est membre
canadien de caritas internationalis
maintenant je lève avant d'aller vers
notre invité puisque année c'est aussi
l'autre effet oui c'est fort ça c'est
quand même l'éclairage que j'aime sont
admises
vous aimez le superchampion ils s'en
vont parce que lille a réponse à tout le
problème c'est qu'elle est c'est moi on
connaît beaucoup de choses mais on n'y
pas vraiment bonne d'un questionnaire ça
comme on le remarque à chaque semaine
mais je pense qu au fur et à mesure vous
allez vous améliorer le seul espoir moi
j'ai redoublé la deuxième année à
l'école c'était pour m'améliorer me
disaient les professeurs
je raconte on recule pour mieux sauter
écoutez on vous a attendu pendant 15
secondes pour vous poser la première
question de notre grand jeu qui vont
pour 20 points et à trois questions à
l'émission chaque question vaut
davantage de points et tout le monde
gagne surtout vous à chaque semaine
voici première question combien de
milliers d'euros une gas ont fui les
violences dans leur pays
laissant derrière eux leurs villages
totalement brûlé combien d'après vous
celui qui se trouve le plus proche de la
bonne réponse
est ce que vous nous proposez des
habitudes qu'ils avaient des
propositions non je pense que ça je
crois c'était au tour de 630 mille
autour de 630 normal précis votre
affaire autour de 630 mais je crois déjà
je voudrais pas vous affrontez mois dans
un combat thématique hockey bariz 1
c'est une très bonne question je me
demande si on se rapproche pas du mignon
ou 900 mille neuf cent mille dans votre
corps d'un million je connais pas trop
jouer au milieu 810 au milieu 800000
bien c'est vous qui avez la bonne
réponse alors ciellement 6 en mai 2010
entre nos mains c'est peut-être que vous
avez une source différente de la nôtre
on vous critique pas là dessus vous
gagner mais suffisamment fin pour les 20
premiers célèbre non faut pas célébrer
c'est important de réparer le sage est
le triomphe modeste
on va aller vers notre spécialiste de la
semaine si vous permettez les sources
skype dominique godbout
bonjour dominique qu'est ce que bon on
va vous voir bonjour dominique bonjour
vous ne voyez oui je le vois c'est en
couleurs j'espère un couleurs d'accord
ça coûte cher la couleur aujourd'hui
alors écoutez dites moi vous revenez de
mission vous étiez sur le terrain vous
avez passé combien de temps une semaine
c'était pour quelles raisons vous
envoyer là-bas parce que développer des
projets sur place pour venir en aide aux
gants avec des partenaires locaux et le
financement des affaires mondiales
canada et de la population canadienne
qui nous ont généreusement donné des
fonds pour répondre à la crise
vous avez dit ruine gamma jédir ou une
gas est ce que il ya des disques tout le
monde commet des erreurs sur mon lit non
les origines ces choses là c'est confus
pour plusieurs personnes je crois oui
effectivement notamment le nom du
myanmar ou birmanie selon si on
reconnaît la junte qui a changé le nom l
état de rats qui nous arrache donc c'est
oui effectivement c'est un peu
mélangeant art à cannes ce serait
l'origine du mot roumegas apparemment
j'ai consulté le mot des encyclopédies
avant de vous parler bien sûr il ya dix
ans un débat là-dessus mais ce serait
l'origine du mot comme iroquois le
canada est un mot d'origine iroquoise
pour je répands mon savoir écouter une
semaine qu'est ce que vous avez vu j vu
en immense en fait l'immense ville
finalement c'est c'est assez
impressionnant c'est assez organisés
mais non je dirais il ya un an c'était
un peu éparpillé la cie surpeuplée mais
c'est des abris quand même très très
rapprochés mais quand même des gens qui
sont dans des abris
il ya des services il ya des points
d'eau il ya des latrines
nous on a construit tout ça on a aussi
construit des abris renforcer donc avec
des colonnes de béton pour que les
réfugiés puissent pas être à la merci
des intempéries comme vous aviez dit
tout à l'heure donc il ya quand même des
améliorations mais je dirais qu'avec la
mousson j'étais là pendant la mousson
puis les routes boueuses ça rend les
choses tellement compliqué l'accès à ces
gens là je dirais qu'il y aura encore
beaucoup beaucoup à faire ici autour de
la table et des questions non mais oui
justement elle donne des nouvelles
plutôt rassurantes on se souvient il ya
eu
l'envoyé spécial du ministre justin
trudeau c'était l'ancien premier
ministre de l'ontario mais ceux qui
étaient sur le terrain qui a décrit une
situation vraiment catastrophique des
gens qui vivaient dans des abris de
fortune qui manquait de tout il n'avait
pas l'un des glissements terrain je
crois me voilà moussa balla il avait
faim il avait soif il n'y avait pas
d'eau à boire il n'y avait même pas de
toilettes de services it génique
thaumaturge et dernier tout à fait ça
fait tout juste quelques mois l'a donc
c'était une situation vraiment difficile
pour ces personnes s'il ya des
améliorations
c'est tant mieux et ce en parle
d'amélioration est ce qu'on peut parler
d'amélioration pour les femmes parce
qu'on sait que suite à ce déplacement
il y avait des mariages forcés et des
viols aux silhouettes ou très violent
des femmes qui se sont retrouvées
enceintes
ac c'est sûr qu'à la star son enfant est
toujours les plus jeunes les femmes et
les jeunes filles dans toutes les
situations humaines
il ya d une orientation qui a été mis en
place il ya des espaces sont réservés
pour les femmes et pour les enfants pour
qu'ils puissent se retrouver pendant la
journée pour discuter entre eux pour
avoir accès à des services ou si c'est
sur que c'est pas parfait c'est ce que
les femmes on parlera encore de sortir
de leur tante moi j'en ai parlé avec
plusieurs kills et moi j'en vois pas mes
enfants chercher du bois pour chauffer
ou pour aller chercher de l'eau j'ai
trop peur pour leur sécurité
c'est sûr qu'ils étaient les enjeux de
sécurité sont sont très préoccupant
encore il le canada avait annoncé je
pense soya certain nombre de moins ce
pas le canada sept premiers ministres
canadiens
donc c'est encore meilleur que ça il
avait dit une solution pour ce qui est
de l'aide humanitaire
ça passe par les femmes est-ce que vous
avez vu des gestes concrets des choses
qu'on ne sait pas qui pourrait permettre
de dire oui il ya une action c'est
sensible ça au niveau des fans ça semble
faire produire avoir des effets quelque
chose que le canada a décidé de faire
par exemple
c'est sûr que la communauté en général
réalise que c'est les femmes qui portent
le fardeau des tâches ménagères par
exemple donc on essaie de leur donner un
soutien à ce niveau là pour pas qu'elle
ait perdre trois heures de temps à aller
chercher de l'eau ou aller chercher du
bois comme les exemples que je donnais
tout allait donc c'est sûr que par
exemple les espaces où si où on leur
offre des services de santé ou des
services pour pour des petits qu'aux
logique aussi parce qu'ils ont vraiment
vécu d'être humains importants
les enfants aussi donc oui ça passe par
la santé ça passe par par exemple
développement et paix on leur a donné
des petits pois long pour cuisiner comme
sa mère elle permet pas du temps aller
chercher du bois pour cuisiner de façon
sécuritaire dans l'eure dans l'arctique
tente donc c'est tout des petits efforts
comme ça c'est sûr qu'il ya beaucoup de
petits gestes qu'on peut faire mais
c'est sûr que les normes culturelles
aussi notre foot ni recompte ils ont des
dynamiques familiales qu'il faut
respecter
mais c'est sûr que on essaye de on a le
mot en anglais afin de leur donner du
pouvoir qu'elles puissent prendre des
décisions malheureusement elle est
réfugié encore le droit de travailler
donc forcément ça les rend vraiment
dépendant à raid humanitaire et aussi
leur dignité est vraiment touché
alors c'est vraiment quelque chose sur
quoi il faut travailler est-ce que vous
avez parlé de situation qui se stabilise
est ce que c'est possible de déjà de
parler de certaines scolarisation non
malheureusement on peut pas parler
scolarisation parce que
les enfants n'ont pas le droit à
l'éducation formelle c'est quand même
compliqué il ya une question d' espaces
dans les camps comme jeux ds et
surpeuplé donc juste de savoir où les
mettre pour aller à l'école
quel curiculum la question de la langue
aussi question de moyens c'est donc si
effectivement ça c'est vraiment une
préoccupation parce que ça va être une
génération perdue donc l'accès à
l'éducation est pauvre il avait dit en
son rapport on devrait prioriser
l'éducation mais le gouvernement du
bangladesh lui veut encore favoriser
d'une situation qui plutôt temporaire
parce que eux espère qu'ils vont
repartir qui vont retourner donc à ce
moment leur initiation qui serait plus
permanente et en ce moment c'est passé
pas discuter vous parlez de personnes
qui espèrent retourner chez eux mais on
sait que c'est des gens qui sont
apatrides ils n'ont pas de nation est ce
que vous sentez sur place comme une
espèce de volonté politique de la part
des responsables d'une yamaha vous savez
and san suu kyi elle a été très critiqué
dans la gestion de ce dossier la santé
vous qu'elle soit prête à l'aiea les
accueillir à nouveau
non je ne sens pas que le myanmar est
prêt à les accueillir et je ne sens pas
non plus que les rangs gars sont prêts à
retourner les conditions ne sont pas du
tout rempli pour une rapatriée à sion 2
et sécuritaire et durable
s'il n'y a pas de doute à ce sujet là
surtout avec donc le rapport avec qui a
été publié en début de semaine par les
nations unies qui parlent de pas de deux
au moins considérer les dirigeants
birmans pour
génocide donc le gouvernement birman
rejeté les conclusions de ce rapport là
et donc à ce moment là s'il ya même pas
une responsabilisation de leur part
comment on peut penser qu'il y aurait
une réconciliation et qu'ils reprennent
confiance pour que les rings à puce
retournée ils ont ils ont peur ils ont
vécu autrement importants et donc à ce
moment ce n'est pas absolument pas et il
ya toute la problématique de savoir qui
prend vraiment les décisions au myanmar
effectivement donc où il avait mentionné
aung san suu kyi qui n'a pas d'autorité
réelle on veut le dire
l'arni garder le contrôle des ministères
les plus importants leur rapport de des
nations unies de cette semaine quand
même parler de pourquoi le point de
fusil son autorité morale
je pense que il ya plusieurs raisons
mais une des hypothèses selon moi c'est
qu'est est là elle a été élu par un
peuple qui soutient le majoritairement
et les actions qui sont faites à
l'encontre lire ligue 1 il les considère
comme des étrangers et ils sont contents
qu'il soit parti il ne veut pas qu'ils
reviennent donc elle est dans une
situation d'impasse est prise entre deux
feux entre lille et généraux et puis la
population qu'il mit au pouvoir d'un
pouvoir précaire c'est moins hypocrite
en équilibre je suis je connais peu
développement et paix donc je suis
surpris mais eux le très agréablement
surpris de voir que non seulement vous
pouvez parler d'une situation
humanitaire d'une tragédie mais vous
avez aussi un discours politique et sans
gêne et sans peur est-ce que c'est
benoit je vous dis ça est-ce que ça ça
peut gêner des fois votre travail sur le
terrain ou c'est vous avez des
discussions avec les gens ccc vous êtes
libre de parler de votre opinion sans
trop vous soucier des comment comment
vous naviguez avec ce sont des questions
extrêmement politique vivement on
discussions franches mais je vais avec
les partenaires sur le terrain parce
qu'on n'a pas de bureau sur le terrain
on travaille avec des partenaires locaux
des gens qui sont au bangladesh depuis
toujours qui travaillent avec les
rengaines depuis très longtemps qu'ils
sont acceptés par les communautés qui
parle le ring a donc ces gens là les
partenaires on va peut-être moins en par
l'innocence que e on va les protéger
c'est sûr mais nous notre mission
développement est passé entre autres 206
business sensibiliser la population
carabine sur des enjeux au sud donc et
de lutter contre les injustices sociales
et de venir en aide aux personnes aux
personnes qui en ont besoin
donc je suis tout à fait savoir pendant
qu'on vous pose une dernière question va
vous proposer à tous qui les gens studio
vous même et puis ceux qui sont à
l'internet de regarder les vidéos numéro
trois pour voir donc d image donnée par
radio canada est en fait c b6 et la bbc
donc on a fait un montage des deux kivu
montrait les débuts de la tragédie il ya
un an
des images qui ont fait le tour du monde
dites moi je suis curieux de savoir est
ce que on ne voit plus ces images des
gens qui quittent la birmanie je me
demande ce parce qu'il n'y a plus de
rouergue qui sont présentement en
transit en transit ou comment ça se
passe effectivement il ya encore des
départs mais c'est vraiment je pense que
depuis le début de l'année 2018 y en a
onze mille dans donc et je pense qu'il y
en a eu dix mille dans les premiers
trois mois de mai 18 donc
essentiellement sas et il y en a presque
plus je dis pas qu'il n'a pas du tout il
y en a aussi qui sont pris dans un
espèce de no man's land à la frontière
entre la birmanie et le bangladesh qui
se sont pas encore rendus dans les camps
mais à tout le moins le gru le groupe
heures le groupe ils sont déjà rendus
dans les camps dernière question mari
oui moi je me demandais dominique
godbout
est ce que dans ce que vous faites vous
retrouver un peu de l'essence de votre
décision de travailler dans ce domaine
c'est une excellente question est oui
tout à fait honnêtement la résilience
dont fait preuve ces gens là c'est assez
c'est une source d'inspiration et aussi
c'est impressionnant oui tout à fait je
pense que il faut pas les oublier il
faut continuer d'avoir espoir et on
apprend toujours de gamin donc oui je
suis très chanceuse de faire le travail
que je fais on a beaucoup appris de vous
aujourd'hui et c'est pas terminé vous
allez poursuivre pas avec nous mais avec
nos collègues de la section anglaise
l'équipe anglaise de radio canada
international
je ne sais trouvèrent keller mais dans
une couple d'heures vous avez un nouveau
rendez vous à 13h15 13h15 ait là va être
leur webmestre à l'équipe anglaise
ils ont besoin d'être effective écoutez
merci beaucoup dominique que deux bouts
de nous avons a lancé l'invitation cette
semaine vous et votre équipe pour
participer à l'émission
c'est comme ça que les choses se passent
et que les bons contacts s'effectue mais
xavi merci alors gonick commune
dominique bout de l'organisation
développement et paix écoutez c'est pas
fini je vais vous proposer maintenant
ensemble à de regarder c'est le jeu de
la grosse boule d'accord deuxième manche
quand j'allume j'allume sinon vous allez
pas et on éteint les éclairages en fait
deux choses en même temps c'est
compliqué voici vous allez reconnaître
dans cette vidéo numéro 4 quelqu'un dont
on a parlé durant les dernières minutes
de la mesure bien sûr qu'ils allaient
vous le savez tous voilà on en fait
jouer ça prend du temps mais c'est parce
que ça fait durer le plaisir
on y va donc je pense que vous avez déjà
la réponse de kiss est déjà présent pour
ceux qui ne l'avaient pas vu les nobel
de la paix ouais exactement
oui et qui figure au musée au manitoba
winnipeg au musée des droits de la
personne
mais là on a mis j'avais fait un petit
bla bla
on a mis sa photo en veilleuse
à cause d'eux peut-être son manque de
position ou le fait qu'elle est là il ya
des gens qui se demandent son devrait
lui envoie lui enlever la citoyenneté
honoraire canadienne bon c'est pas
sérieux c'est pas un vieux débat mais
c'est un débat qui a pris des arrêtés
sur cette somme est tout à fait pas bon
à l'occasion de la première anniversaire
beaucoup de choses qui qui remonte à la
surface
voici c'est le jeu de la grosse boule et
je vais vous demander de me dire quel
est le titre exact où le site le plus
proche de la réalité de hong sangsoo cui
je veux m'amuser un peu pour voir et le
connaître quel est son titre mais les
premiers ministres d'accord vous dites
première ministre mais à titre
honorifique comme on l'a dit donc est
monté
c'est la question piège à ce moment là
qu'un jour les vérifier quel chef du
gouvernement français quand ce sont les
militaires qui mène moi j'ai beaucoup de
difficulté à me prononcer là-dessus
répondu je dirais qu'elle serait une
reprise est ce qu'elle est présidente
mais de je-ne-sais-quoi du myanmar mais
qu'est ce que c'est mis à mal en ce
moment
hockey pendant qu'il ya beaucoup de
questions à la travers la réponse à la
question maintenant nous avons la wii
vous avez toujours les bandes répond non
merci j'ai aucune des autres termes il
ya un terme consacré les chefs de quels
que soient mes ministres
vraiment c'est pas trop et bien produit
en première résidence vous allez plutôt
ouvert la présidente comme moi j'ai dix
premières minutes les équipes premières
minis smadja l'ex président alors
écoutez elle est conseillère spéciale de
l'état et porte parole de la présidence
de la république de l'union de birmanie
n'est pas président mais elle est comme
sur le podium une présidente
mais c'est très symbolique c'est sûr que
ça reste très symbolique c'est le
véritable pouvoir c'est la meilleure
ouais ça les conseils à imaginer alors
c'est difficile pour une conseillère des
fois de ces prénoms mais généralement
les journalistes en parlent en termes de
première mi temps ici
celui-ci c'est ça qu'on voit s'appelle à
faire des larmes et qu'on la voit elle
je sais pas me suis pas dans la tête de
l'armée je veux pas l'être c'est vrai
aussi à la radio s'est plus fait c'est
plus simple à dire on s'entend sur
dirigeant d'air de la birmanie du genre
permane moi je n'aurais pas escale à
voir des dirigé ça c'est la grande
question
alors voilà ça c'est un gros débat c'est
pas c'est pas nous qui allons le régler
je vais à l'iss on va sur le t2 le tpo
le savent pour regarder nous expliquer
on a mal expliqué la semaine dernière
c'est toujours ma faute
il y a c'est une c'est une fiche
technique n'y mettons sur le web
seuls nous y avons accès et ça nous
permet de vous montrer à quoi va
ressembler vers l'heure du midi donc
dans 30 minutes
lorsqu'on va mettre cette émission en
archives sur le site web de radio-canada
d'intention vous allez voir non
seulement la vidéo de youtube ou sur la
version youtube vous allez aussi voir ce
qu'on vous propose cette semaine nos
meilleurs coûts et nos archives qui sont
associées au sujet des missions
là vous voyez donc une reproduction à
vendin de ce qui va être un monde plus
tard aujourd'hui j'espère je m'explique
bien aujourd'hui très bien alors on voit
ici trois des onze sujets qu'on a mis en
ligne au cours de la dernière année sur
la question des orignaux et jeu on va
cliquer sur le premier peut-être est-ce
que vous reconnaissez un de vos articles
lorsqu'un peuple qui a écrit tu la halle
et chantal chante m
oui souvent c'est le plus récent qu'on a
les femmes au centre de la stratégie des
du canada 24 mai vous avez fait une
entrevue je pense quelque part à travers
tout ça il n'y avait pas d'entrevue
résumer un peu le rapport qui avait été
fait par l'envoyé spécial du canada ont
dit c'est un aspect vraiment beaucoup de
choses à lire merci on va on va
retourner en arrière ça commençait enfin
le bac mais ça reste comme ça et on va
aller vers la crise d'héroïne gas le
canada ne peut agir seule pour venir en
aide si je pense un peu plus vieux que
moi comme article belle photo et c'est
écrit par marie jo bats je pense c'est
une autre vie en plus en plus de ça il
me semble est-ce qu'on a la capacité
technique
il devait y avoir une entrevue d'écouter
un extrait ouais d'accord et c'est avec
qui d'après vous maryse ou qui avait le
sens de l'accord du centre de régisseur
grand champ de recherche droits de la
personne à l'université d'ottawa
journées inpacq monsieur pas que hier il
ya le rapport de monsieur v qui a été
présenté un rapport donc sur la
situation des régates donc pas ces gens
qui vous se tasser envoyez vous pouvez
aller plus loin que la simple diffusion
de notre émission à chaque semaine vous
allez beaucoup d le dos est plus sérieux
que nous nous on fait des choses donc
c'est d'être dans les détails vous irez
vers ces articles de radio canada
international
voilà je veux simplement donner la clé
pour utiliser notre site pour suivre
profondeur bien sûr j'ai pour vous
maintenant une petite surprise
qu'est ce qu'un juste des points très
hollywood et au niveau des princes un
teint vous avez vous aviez vous de l'ebn
la bonne réponse est non mais moi aussi
je l'avais parce que moi j'ai dit
qu'elle était prise dans j'avais
vraiment tous les trois très bonnes
vacances à chaque 30 + 20 54 ans alors
je suis vraiment pour le dernier jeu de
la grosse boule
ça va être très facile vous allez voir
vous allez avoir 50 points sur moi je
m'en allais il a hâte de partir on
dirait j'ai agi fin je pense que je me
donne faim en parlant de l'heure du midi
moi j'ai toujours faim
quelle est la population totale dans le
monde d'euros inga on a dit plutôt
qu'ils étaient 600 milles qu'ils étaient
maintenant rendu la population totale
dans le monde de ring à plusieurs ont
immigré en angleterre par exemple au fil
des années mais la population totale
enfin c'est pas c'est un grand peuple
sans pays s'en fait ça d'où la
difficulté des faits deux de procéder à
un dénombrement c'est à dire que les
roms sont à l'heure dans le même cas à
la même situation
il ya les palestiniens pourraient
peut-être être placés dans cette
position où dans cette je veux pas dire
de bêtises franchement je sais pas non
vous savez pas non je ne parle pas 50
points je veux bien humide et admis un
million et demi à peu près d'accord a
bien émis faites vos jeux
elle va plus faites vos jeux moi toute
façon j'étais pas bonne sur les chiffres
mais je vais dire autour des 2 autour de
deux pays non bien sûr j'irai elle va
situé près d'un million 800 mille litres
alors 1.5 million c'est la bonne réponse
enfin vous avez 100%
non jamais
4 n'avait pas répondu bien la bonne
réponse non au dessus des 70 pour faire
plus d'efforts salaire doubler votre
année où est donc quoi c'est terminé oui
j'ai un plaisir malin mon père pour
faire une affaire de chez surtout en
mathématiques lui qui était professeur
de maths ou moi mon père était aussi
preuve dès maintenant et je suis allé
une seule fois en argentine cdc l'oat 10
ans arrivé une seule fois avec une
dysplasie tafer sulement qui est fait et
les voir c'est pas une grosse tête dans
le doute
non mais lui il était prof alors son
sein son niveau était vraiment est ce
qu'il enseigne à l'université ou non
l'école secondaire ça vous n'avez pas
des bonnes relations avec papa c'est
encore douloureux
c'était mon père c'est un bon père non
non absolument est décédé quand j'avais
14 ans a pas eu tant de mal à faire son
travail c'est intéressant tant les
départs parce que moi mes parents qui
est année au début du 20e siècle et qui
ont fait des 5ème année forte alors mon
père voulait toujours savoir ce qu'on
avait appris à l'école alors revenez il
nous poser des questions
ils nous lancent un peu des tests peu
comme vous faites pour des questions
pour voir si on avait retenu quelque
chose de l'école parce que lui il rémy
peut-être poursuivre ses études alors
c'est ce goût était resté belle leçon de
vie que même très très belle leçon du je
pense qu'on va arrêter la plus belle
ville comme ça je sais pas lesquels
belle façon de conclure merci beaucoup
alice chantal de chandelle de trinh-duc
semaine également ça m'a fait plaisir
léo gimeno même regarder tous les quatre
la caméra numéro 1 1
il faut forer un il
2 il ya trois donc s'effacer ans à la
semaine prochaine à bail